ado même l'âge
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
g
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le mur
[ __ ]
c'est le
caramel à m bernard les paysans
j'ai explosé
alors là
l'a3 vers la mauritanie d'éclater telle
sorte qu'elle est d'une sensualité des
bombes à oui c'est daniel avec mathieu
avec mathieu l'impression de l'infini en
plus
chez leurs patients qui se passe
vraiment quelque chose oui elle peut
quand même goûté l'élève de bernard
c'est vraiment c'est pas à son indiana
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai tenté
est ce que vous savez qu'il fait bah
c'est moi sensuelle avec manu c'est pas
mal mais j'aimais bien
isabelle et isabelle il ya de l'amour
vous voulez retourner une dernière danse
avec mathieu
[Applaudissements]
comment
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le début d'émission